I'm mr. wonderful here and I want to
talk about this week's episode of ask
mr. wonderful it's inspired by an email
question from Atlanta I'm gonna read it
to you you see what I mean hi my name is
Elizabeth from Atlanta I'm one of your
Instagram followers from way back in the
early shark tank days and I've recently
subscribed to your YouTube channel with
the whole ask mr. wonderful thing you
recently posted an instant pic with your
white underwear air-drying in your
kitchen on hangers how gross and the
whole place was a mess what's with that
are you going crazy and Quarantine or
something and how are you living your
life these days okay Elizabeth
now just one second on the underwear
okay here are the aforementioned
underwear these are not just any
underwear these are Swiss Zimmer Li
underwear there's very few things I
really really indulge myself in but
these poppies these Zimmer Lee's are
made from Egyptian cotton
absolutely beautiful 78 bucks a pair
they're not cheap they don't get any
better when it comes to men's underwear
now I washed them in a delicate cycle in
the washing machine but there's no way
I'm putting them in the dryer it's gonna
wreck this beautiful band and take the
zing out of the Zimmer Lee if you know
what I mean and these things are very
package friendly you want to keep them
soft and cuddly
so there's method to my madness I'm not
crazy hanging those things up to air-dry
that's why I do it that's how I always
do it I never put the Zimmer Lee's in
the dryer that would just kill them
that's crazy and yeah the place is a
mess I agree but it's organized chaos I
know where everything is here I don't
want to move it I'll lose it if I move
it I want to keep it in the same place
it's not messy it's it's laid out
aggressively that's what it is and look
yeah I'm in quarantine like everybody
else but I'm doing a lot of stuff during
the day so I love the question now that
we've got the zero noise out of the way
and I'm gonna walk you through a day in
my life I like the idea of a day in the
life of quarantine
what's that like so let's check it out
here we go
[Music]
okay it's early morning but the routine
is always the same I get up and around
let's have a look at the time here yeah
six o'clock I think it's important to
keep that routine you got to get up
early work out a little bit and start
the day and here we go you know I don't
endorse products that I don't use
personally I just don't want to do it if
I'm going to get a sponsor which I have
you know on my youtube channel I'm gonna
use the product I want to know all about
it and I want it to work for me why
would I endorse it for somebody else if
I don't try it on myself you gotta eat
your own cooking I really believe that
particularly when it comes to throwing
your name behind something like in the
wine business I drink my wines I make my
wines same thing on any product I use or
I show are put on the sponsor here I
want to know all about it
now I'm like any other guy really wasn't
into skincare for a long time but I am
now and I'll tell you why I use a lot of
makeup a ton of makeup this stuff is
powder for television and generally I
put it on and I got a lot of real estate
you don't want to be shiny on TV so I'm
putting this stuff on my you know my my
golden dome a lot and a ton of it under
my eyes like this and around my nose and
here where it gets shiny if you see
people that are on TV they look great on
the camera when you see them in person
they come off the set they look like
they're dead they got so much makeup
packed on but that makeups really crap
for you it gets in your pores and it
agitates like crazy so I got into a
product you know T's Handley it's it's
it's a it's a skin care system for men
they send you all the stuff you need you
don't have to know anything about all
the different products although you get
plenty of them and they tell you in
order to use them the wash is a basic
wash for your face morning or night for
me and this scrub takes all the crap out
of my pores so let me show you how this
stuff works
wash is very simple all you need is just
a little warm water put some on your
hands put on your face really refreshing
and then you just wash it off with water
then I'll show you how to use the scrub
the scrubs amazing now you still don't
have the dirt out that's the first step
this is the stuff I really love the
scrub it's got a little you know little
particles in it or whatever and this
gets out the makeup in the dirt
of course I've asked the t's Handley
people for a special deal for my viewers
and you'll find out more if you click on
the link in the description skincare for
men who knew I'm using it now because I
want to keep looking like mr. wonderful
honor the exercise bike you know this
I've been doing this for years this is
like a total routine research I read it
on the bike today I'm doing mine med I'm
an investor in this company
remember this is micro dosing
psychedelics is a medicine
so I'm going to be interviewing the CEO
later but I want to read the latest
research so get on the bike
fire it up I just feel if you're gonna
be in self-isolation
you got to stick to the routine I mean
that's what it takes
some people say have cotton let that
plane go check yourself up so right now
we're just gonna let that heat and then
when it comes to a boil we're gonna
leave the eggs in for exactly nine
minutes and then plunge them into
ice-cold water yeah it's a lot of work
but I care about how my hard-boiled egg
looks
frankly I don't want to see that dark
blackness on the edge of the yolk so I'm
going to avoid that by doing this out of
the fridge into cold water and then let
it heat and boil to nine minutes
there I've let you in on a great secret
chef's wonderful always wants a
perfectly cooked hard-boiled egg that's
how you do it
[Music]
[Music]
Oh so let me give you a little tour of
the facility yeah I know everybody calls
it messy but you know this functionality
going on here yeah I got some laundry
drying there too you know but bottom
line is I broadcast out of here this is
my social media kind of kitchen center
you can see all the equipment there but
I also broadcast to the networks I have
a network camera and I stuck that in a
bedroom so we'll walk down here and have
a look at it
yeah I got short pants on in a suit top
why cuz I'm about to broadcast to
network they're not gonna see it I'm
wearing flip-flops but this is how this
place works so this is a bedroom you can
see the bed it's a mess it's got a bunch
of stuff on it
lighting I'm bouncing off a white
ceiling for a good image that's a
network camera that's actually
controlled out of New York they can
control it so can I so that this is
actually a full network broadcast
facility this is the computer that
controls it and also lets it be
controlled remotely this is the green
screen background so there's the shark
tank set and I could use that as a
background if I'm doing a shoot for
let's say ABC on Shark Tank but let me
show you some other options let's say
I'm gonna do a broadcast and talk about
financial services I can go up to where
these images are stored and say okay
let's do let's let's talk about the
exchange-traded fund industry and that's
a background of a company I have an
interesting called oh she airs and then
we can go and look at something maybe a
little more eclectic let's find
something like oh here's Dubai this is
the tallest building in the world so I
could be broadcasting with a Dubai
background so let's see what that looks
like so here I am I'm going to be in
Dubai and so I'm gonna go to the screen
here turn off the bars so now we have
the feed of the camera and I want to
adjust can you see me holding this
little camera I'm shooting with but
here's the here's the joystick but let
me it lets me adjust the direction of
the camera the way New York would be
doing and you can see if that's moving
and so I'm going to Center it and then
I'm going to zoom in so that I only have
a background see how that works kind of
cooling go up a little bit because my
hips cut off there there we go there we
go so there I am in Dubai and you can
see another image of that and felt the
lighting there's a little soft so I
could change the lighting as well
watch this I'm gonna go over and because
the lighting was set for social media
norms off the ceiling I'm gonna go
direct LED lighting by just tilting
these give you an idea of how the kind
of network thing works so that's a
straight on lighting you can see where
I'm gonna be sitting there and that
background we're talking about now look
at the shot setting up for the network
there you go and you see the much better
kind of see the screen down here too
yeah and then they would further with
that camera over there they would
further enhance it or change it or
change the coloration of it or zoom in
zoom out I can do it with this joystick
right here but the network can do it too
and that is how a broadcast works that
is how you can broadcast anywhere in the
world I'm doing three of them today so I
think that's very efficient you know
it's it's a little funky chicken in
terms of taking over a bedroom but you
know it's it's part of this I call it a
studio really and then when I feel like
it which I love to do is if I'm gonna
lay down a track actually for this show
you're gonna watch I'm gonna write some
music tonight and I'm gonna mix it into
this 24 track recorder I've got three
different guitars here and if you if
you're into music you know that like
this is a really interesting guitars and
nylon guitar on an electric body a Godin
which is a really interesting
manufacturer here's a classic 69
Telecaster I've talked about how tough
this is such an unforgiving [ __ ] to
play it but it has such an amazing sound
drum this is an old-school drum machine
but I also use a software product called
ez drummer which is absolutely amazing
you basically lay down your tracks some
of you who are into this and you can
actually you know write a drum sequence
and play it and sort of say well do I
like it or not I'm thinking a sort of
yeah kind of a jazzy thing that's gonna
be the groove for this piece I'm doing
for this show for this episode
ask mr. wonderful I'm still working on
it I like to mic my own amp because I
want the room tone a lot of guys will go
right into the board I don't agree you
really want to you know think about
old-school when you're talking about
this I'm using this really interesting
tascam analog to digital I mean it's
easy to use and its really great for
laying down it has a Bluetooth interface
so you can put ezdrummer to it for those
times when I just want to hang here's
the balcony David John came to visit me
we did some social distancing we sat
about 6 feet apart and we had masks on
we just watch the ocean roll by like you
are right now oh one last thing a lot of
cooking a lot of cooking a lot of frozen
goods but today I'm going to probably do
a salad with some tortellini yeah that's
what I'm thinking about and I put my
whites on to cook just for the old
routine the old chef wonderful thing but
it's a little messy but you know and
yeah my Japanese fishing pants are
drying I don't like to put those in the
dryer either I want them because they're
silk and they're beautiful and I wear
these Japanese fishing pants pretty well
every day oh and I love to have some
work it's they just you know they last a
long time and they're beautiful these
are the new love pop greeting cards
which are actually bouquets of flour for
Mother's Day I'm going to be sending my
wife one of these kind of cute but bow
Hana which there's another shark tank
product these are actually water silly
water lily seeds that are pop way better
than popcorn I'm gonna be selling these
on QVC in the next couple of days but
that's kind of a tour of what's cookin
so to speak oh yeah Bengie lockers are
those another shark tank deal that's a
lot that you can actually open with your
fingertip let's grab one this thing is
one look I've got I've got it the CES
Innovation Award check it out
third year in a row Benji Locke so it's
actually a lock that you can program
your finger in to shift this one I have
programmed yet but we'll see yeah it
opens right that open with my thumb I
probably put to my index and my thumb
finger into it I just think it's just a
terrific I use them on the bike all the
time oh yeah this is a cool bike these
guys in Miami made me I don't own the
company I paid for it but I just love it
it's it's a mr. wonderful I cruise all
over Miami in this thing yeah it's great
and of course I've got my m95 mask right
here and you got the tour you definitely
got the tour all right guys I gotta get
back to work I hope you like that tour I
know it's messy but it's organized chaos
hi everybody I really hope you enjoyed
that kind of snapshot of a day in the
life of a quarantine dude now the thing
about being in quarantine are isolated
like this is you can't let it turn into
Groundhog Day you got to do different
stuff you have to shake up the routine a
little bit yeah it's important to work
out and focus on the things you've got
to get done every day but you got to
have a little difference to it maybe
take a bike ride run or something just
get out for a while do whatever you have
to do to keep it interesting now if
you're an entrepreneur and I know lots
of them you got to stay focused on your
customers right now you want to make
sure they remember who you are and your
employees that's the DNA of your
business and today we have all these
wonderful Technology tools to use this
is what's so unique about this pandemic
we have some really interesting ways to
stay in touch with each other even if
we're
isolated and that's important for
business no question about that but the
key is you got to enjoy your life every
day of it even though sometimes it gets
a little crazy
anyways look my friends stay safe and
remember we're all in this together
you've heard that a thousand times but
it's so true and don't forget this
wash your hands until next time mr.
wonderful and by the way stay wonderful